hey guys how's it going it's justine and
i am so excited because today
we are doing an unboxing of the insta360
one
i've actually been testing this camera
out for a few months i've taken it on
several trips i took it to tahoe i took
it to hawaii and i've been really loving
the shots that you can get with this
and i'm not over exaggerating i might
seem a little bit excited but when you
guys see the really cool stuff that this
thing can do
you're going to be just as excited as i
[Music]
am
this one is a dog mount you can get this
on insta360s website so you better
believe
we're gonna be putting this on maddie
today we've got a few other accessories
there's a bike mount
there's a helmet mount and a chest strap
so guess what
i'm gonna be on a bike today as well
this video is gonna get crazy
so there's a bunch of different pieces
that go into this so this is
uh well i guess you could call it a
selfie stick but it's so much more than
that
as it says on here this is designed for
bullet time
here is the actual camera what's great
is it has this little protective case on
it so it'll protect the lens
so you can see those lens on both sides
there's one here
one here and down here on the bottom
this flips up and you can plug this
directly into your iphone
here's the on button you can also use
this to take photos and videos
here's the sd card slot and this is also
where you will be putting the selfie
stick we can call it the bullet time
stick
there's also another little place right
here where you can screw on an extra
tripod the best part about the insta360
one is this
stick you actually will never see it in
any of your videos or photos
it magically erases it from all of your
footage so it kind of just looks like a
drone is following you
we also have a bullet time handle this
will all make sense i promise
this screws into the bottom of the
bullet time
selfie stick and you basically will be
able to swing this around
to get the bullet time shots and yes you
are going to look absolutely ridiculous
but it is
so worth it for the shots that you'll be
able to get the stick also extends
if you haven't noticed i'm not going to
swing this around in my office because i
will
definitely hit that camera it's also got
some usb cables which are very very
important
i'm sure you guys have never seen this
before new technology
so this just charges with a micro usb
cable they included as well
so i already have the insta360 one app
installed on my phone
you plug it in okay so we're gonna hit
this little plus button right here
so you can look at your 360 album your
iphone album or you can choose to shoot
a new
video or photo and here we are it is
live i can scroll around here so you can
see me
you can see my office and this is all
happening
pretty much live on your phone like all
we did was plug this camera
into your phone oops i didn't even mean
to hit that right now
we just took a picture so you don't need
to have this plugged into your phone to
shoot videos or photos
one press to take a picture two press to
record video
and when you have the bullet time handle
on you press it three times
and that's when you swing it around your
head to get the bullet time shots one of
the things that i really like is i love
free capture because if you don't want
to post a 360 video
on your instagram or on twitter you can
just kind of use this and just film
then go back in later and choose the
shots that you want pivot points will
allow you to sort of play connect
the dots in your 360 video it'll
automatically connect each point to give
you really great cinematic shots
you can just go out and film with this
thing and not have to worry about
getting the shot
because it's 360. you've got the shot
this also has a thing called flow state
stabilization so you can go running
you can put this on your dog you can put
it on your bike and it'll give you that
look and feel of it being a gimbal but
it's not
it's this once this is connected you can
see all of those really amazing things
that you just
shot you can edit it save it out and
then you can also share it
we need to get out of my office so i can
give you guys a proper demo of this
we're going to be going over a lot of
things so get ready because we're going
outside
i'm gonna test this out and put this in
the middle of this jungle gym double tap
to start the video
will i get hurt today that's the
question and what's cool is you can use
the editing feature inside of the app so
this
is being shot right now in 360 but i can
follow myself around using pivot points
so it's a 360 video but you guys are
seeing it
in a not 360 video this is so fun holy
crap why have we never come here before
we got a slide there's a slide there's
oh wow there's so many things i can do
here
i'm having way more fun
this is like a parkour dream let's plug
it in and see what we just got
we made perfect timing because the
children have arrived
one of the best things is if you look
down where's the stick
it's gone it is automatically removed
here's a quick look at the iphone
interface
so right here there's a 360 button
option and if you click that it'll give
you
various modes that you can choose from
there's a circle view and a rectangle
view
you can choose from the front or the
back camera to put in each section
this is one of my favorite views this is
a split view and i've been using this a
lot in igtv if you guys follow me on
instagram you probably have already seen
me experimenting with this
switching from the 16x9 aspect ratio to
the 9x16 will give you this perfect
vertical look
you can change up the views from the top
and the bottom and then export it out
and you've got yourself the perfect igtv
video now i want to show you guys a
demonstration of the flow state
stabilization this is probably one of my
favorite features because it essentially
will make it look like
you have a drone following you but you
don't you're holding
this camera on a stick double tap
okay it's recording now
[Music]
lost my phone again
so you guys may notice that i have my
phone in my hand but a few minutes ago i
realized that the phone had dropped out
of my pocket while i was running around
like a fool
let's see if we can replay the uh exact
moment that i lost my phone
yes so look it's crazy because you
cannot even
see the stick when does the phone fall
out
at what point so you can see the stick
in the shadow
there it goes there it goes yes the
phone
there it goes that's amazing
wow what a moment captured here in 360.
[Music]
we've got a dog harness here and we've
got the mount so what we're going to do
is we're going to put this on my dog and
we're going to see what happens
because you can get some really cool
stabilization shots i've seen a few
previews of this before so now it's time
to try it out on my own dog
hey manny let's put your little oh
who have you got on your back what do
you got on your back
look at this yeah maddie
you're the best he looks like a little
robot boy
are you a robot right now we are heading
to the dog park we're going to test this
out and
see what happens maddie is loving it
he is super into it
[Music]
time to see what we got from maddie oh
my goodness this is awesome
oh my gosh this is amazing this is such
a cool perspective of my dog
i wonder if he knows how cool he looks
[Music]
there's also a desktop app that you guys
can use to export higher quality videos
than what i'm showing you guys here
i just choose to use my iphone because
it's so easy and convenient but i just
wanted you guys to know that there is a
desktop option if you choose to do that
this is the tiny planet mode you can use
any aspect ratio you want but i think it
looks best in the square
let me know what you guys think
[Music]
here's an example of before and after
using the flow state stabilization as
you guys can see here there are two
different versions of this
if you do decide to turn off the flow
state stabilization you won't be able to
use free capture
it's pretty easy to turn on and off in
the settings but my recommendation
is leave it on because it looks way
better we need to talk about bullet time
some of you guys
may be too young to remember this small
little movie called the matrix it was a
good film if you haven't seen it you
should look it up
but this is one of my favorite features
so this is a little handle
that spins around like this the handle
attaches to the bullet time
selfie stick like this and then
essentially
you're gonna swing this around your head
you
will look like an idiot i promise you it
is something that will happen
but when you see the footage it is worth
it you're gonna triple tap the power
button
to automatically go into bullet time
mode when my sister and i were in hawaii
i was
up on top of this mountain swinging this
around my head and people were like what
are you doing
i said hold up wait a minute let me show
you so i plugged this camera into my
phone in the top of a mountain and i
showed people this
and they were blown away so now let me
demonstrate let me show you how cool i
look
oh look at my friends they are flocking
from miles away
and you can experiment with moving your
arm different ways to see what works
best but
i'll tell you what man look at this
come swim with me
[Music]
[Applause]
all right now we're going to be testing
out the hyperlapse feature and for that
i rented myself a bike safety first kids
so this is the bike mount
this is sold separately on insta360's
website so you can just pop that on
there
and i think we're about ready to test
this out bye-bye
do i come back wait how do i have brakes
here we go
i'll be here okay should i just drive
[Music]
around
i was too impatient to see what my
footage looks like
wow this is so neat
[Music]
i created that hyperlapse very easily i
just added some pivot points so that i
can move the camera around as i was
moving along
once those are all set you can go in and
change the speed from 1x all the way up
to 64x
export it out and you're all done
well guys thanks so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video i had
so much fun playing with insta360 one
let me know if you guys liked the video
and if you'd like to see me do anything
else crazy or fun with this
leave those in the comments below and
i'll see you guys in my next video
uh this is great see you later
whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
you